hey guys it's luke bryan here on
buzzfeed
and i'm going to be reading first tweets
they might be nasty
[Music]
actually think luke bryan is so
attractive i want to choke
don't do that get some water my wife
wants to choke me
sometimes luke bryan just came on the
radio and my response was to bite my lip
and moan
well hopefully you weren't driving bite
my lip and moan how do you
mmm luke bryan's thighs need their own
fan page you beautiful man you been
cycling a lot
the thighs are quite toned however the
beer belly
is not luke brian could throw his beer
on me and i would thank you
probably gonna happen one of these days
oh luke bryan can pelvic
thrust my face all day some of my fans
need to
maybe go to church luke bryan ain't a
pair of jeans
that disagree with his ass seems like
you all
stare at my ass and jeans quite a bit
that's okay sells tickets
luke bryan is so cute i would saddle up
and ride his bull
24 7 if i could
i do have a soul and a heart and i'm not
just a piece of meat
my google history luke bryan's ass and
his tight jeans
i've googled that before i want luke
bryan to choke me out with his thighs
black
widow style buzzfeed is scandalous
my thighs seem to be the subject of a
lot of
sexual fantasies thank you guys for that
and
you know through all this let's do
remember i i do have music
luke bryan smirks like that my underwear
disappears
jesus i'll try to save you the smirk
if i won an award i would thank god and
then luke bruns parents
for creating a beautiful person my
parents are beautiful people
love you mom and dad i want luke bryan
to sing to my [ __ ]
what is a bussy hold on real quick let
me see
google this is me googling [ __ ]
[ __ ] as urban dictionary so eloquently
points out is a combination of the words
boy and to you you get it i get it
do y'all know what these say thanks
buzzfeed and thanks for all my thirsty
fans who obviously um yeah i'll be
praying for you guys
i do not want to see your google
histories my new album born here live
here die here
is out right now have a nice day
[Music]
you